>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A LITTLE OVER 15 MONTHS AGO, A
GROUP OF CHINESE SCIENTISTS
WORKING ON THE GROUND AT THE
SCENE OF A NEW VIRUS CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THE NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM A
GOVERNMENT LAB IN WUHAN.
THESE CHINESE SCIENTISTS SAID
THAT IN THE CLEAREST POSSIBLE
TERMS AND POSTED ON THE
INTERNET.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, THIS WAS
AN AMAZING AND IMPORTANT STORY
AND PLAUSIBLE.
WE EXPECTED A FLURRY OF MEDIA
INTEREST IN IT.
WHERE DID THE VIRUS COME FROM?
IT WAS WORTH KNOWING AS PEOPLE
WERE DYING OF IT.
NOBODY ASKED THE QUESTION.
INSTEAD, THERE WAS SILENCE
PUNCTUATED BY ANTI-ASIAN RACISM
AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THAT'S WHERE IT STOOD MORE THAN
A YEAR UNTIL JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
SUDDENLY FOR REASONS WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND, ALL THE SMIRKING
MORONS IN THE AMERICAN NEWS
MEDIA CHANGED THEIR VIEW
OVERNIGHT.
OF COURSE, CORONAVIRUS ESCAPED
FROM A CHINESE LAB.
DO YOU THINK IT CAME FROM A WET
MARKET?
AN AVALANCHE OF EVIDENCE
CONFIRMED THAT THE FIRST CORONA
VICTIMS WERE RESEARCHERS WORKING
WITH BAT VIRUSES AT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
BUZZ FEED OBTAINED THOUSANDS OF
E-MAILS THAT TONY FAUCI KNEW
FROM THE BEGINNING THAT COVID
WAS MANUFACTURED IN CHINA IN
DANGEROUS EXPERIMENTS THAT HE
HELPED PAY FOR.
THE LAB LEAK THEORY WAS NEVER
CRAZY.
IT WAS ALWAYS LIKELY TRUE.
SO WHY DO THEY LIE TO US ABOUT
IT FOR SO LONG?
A SHOCKING NEW PIECE OF ALL
PLACES THE CELEBRITY SUCK-UP
MAGAZINE VANITY FAIR ANSWERS
THAT MAGAZINE IN GREAT DETAIL.
YOU SHOULD READ IT.
IN SHORT, MANY RESEARCH
SCIENTISTS ARE ADDICTED TO
AMERICAN TAX DALLAS.
IF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND HOW RECKLESSLY THEY
HAVE BEHAVED, ENDANGERED THE
WORLD WITH THEIR POORLY
REGULATED LABS IN CHINA, THAT
MONEY MIGHT DRY UP.
AS A FORMER NFC OFFICIAL PUT IT,
IF THE PANDEMIC STARTED AS PART
OF A LAB LEAK, IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DO TO VIROLOGY
ABOUT WHAT CHERNOBYL DID TO
NUCLEAR SIGNS.
THEY LIED ABOUT IT.
THEY INTIMIDATED ANYONE THAT
TRIED TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THAT INCLUDED THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CDC.
ROBERT REDFIELD RECEIVED DEATH
THREATS AFTER HE SUGGESTED A
VIRUS CAME FROM THE LAB.
>> I'M OF THE POINT OF VIEW THAT
THE MOST LIKELY ETIOLOGY OF THIS
PATHOGEN IN WUHAN WAS FROM A
LABORATORY.
YOU KNOW, ESCAPED.
OTHER PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THAT IS FINE.
SCIENCE WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR RESPIRATORY
PATHOGENS TO AFFECT THE LAB
WORKER.
>> Tucker: YOU'D THINK THE WORLD
WOULD STOP AND ASK FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS LIKE WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT?
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE?
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
I WAS THREATENED AND OSTRACIZED
BECAUSE I PROPOSED ANOTHER
HYPOTHESIS REDFIELD TOLD VANITY
FAIR.
HE SAID I EXPECTED IT FROM
POLITICIANS BUT I DIDN'T EXPECT
IT FROM SCIENCE.
MAYBE HE SHOULD HAVE.
REDFIELD HAD DARED TO BUCK THE
ORTHODOXY.
IT BEGAN FEBRUARY 19, 2020, JUST
AS THE VIRUS WAS GETTING TO THIS
COUNTRY.
AT THAT MOMENT, THE LANCET
PUBLISHED A LETTER SIGNED BY 27
SCIENTISTS.
THAT LETTER DECLARED FLATLY THAT
THE CORONAVIRUS DID NOT
ORIGINATE IN A LAB IN WUHAN AND
YOU'D HAVE TO BE A BIGOT TO
BELIEVE OTHERWISE.
NOW, THAT LETTER WE NOW KNOW WAS
ORGANIZED BY PETER DAZEK.
HE HAS EVERYTHING TO GAIN BY
PRETENDING THAT COVID CAME FROM
A WET MARKET.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH AT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
HE SELECTED OTHER SIGNATORIES TO
THE LANCET LETTER SO THIS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WOULD
REMAIN SECRET.
AT ONE POINT, HE WROTE TO
ANOTHER SCIENTIST ALSO WORKING
ON GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
TELLING HIM NOT TO SIGN THE
LETTER.
HERE'S WHY.
"WE'LL PUT IT OUT IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T LINK IT BACK TO OUR
COLLABORATION SO WE MAXIMIZE IN
THE INDEPENDENT VOICE."
SO THE WHOLE THING WAS A FRAUD.
YET IT WORKED.
IT WAS IN THE LANCET.
EVERYBODY TRUSTED THE LANCET.
TONY FAUCI HIMSELF CITED
DASZAK'S LETTER.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE EVOLUTION
OF THE VIRUS IN BATS AND WHAT IS
OUT THERE NOW, IT'S VERY, VERY
STRONGLY LEANING TOWARD THIS
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN ARTIFICIALLY
OR DELIBERATELY MANIPULATED THE
WAY THE MUTATIONS NATURALLY
EVOLVED.
A NUMBER OF VERY QUALIFIED
EVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGISTS HAVE
SAID THAT EVERYTHING ABOUT THE
STEP-WISE EVOLUTION OVER TIME
STRONGLY INDICATES THAT IT
EVOLVED IN NATURE AND JUMPED
SPECIES.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN.
THIS IS THE STORY ABOUT THE
SELF-LICKING ICE CREAM CONE THAT
IS THE FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY.
THEY NEVER DO ANYTHING.
DIDN'T HAVE WMD IN IRAQ.
IT WASN'T JUST TONY FAUCI AND
THE BUREAUCRATS THAT CITED THAT
LETTER.
SELF-DESCRIBED FACT CHECKERS
THAT CONTROL THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION IN OUR COUNTRY USED
THE LANCET TO CENSOR ANYBODY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT MENTIONED THE
POSSIBILITY OF A LACK  -- LAB
LEAK.
27 SCIENTISTS SAY IT'S NOT TRUE.
ONE SCIENTIST SAID DECENTRALIZED
RADICAL AUTONOMOUS SEARCH TEAMS,
SOMETHING THAT ALL SCIENTISTS
SHOULD BE.
JAMIE METZEL JOINED THE GROUP.
LAST YEAR IT WAS BECOMING CLEAR
THAT THE LAB LEAK THEORY WAS NOT
A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
IN FACT, IT WAS PLAUSIBLE.
>> I THINK THAT IF I HAD TO BET
BASED ON WHAT I READ AND LOGIC,
I WOULD BET IT'S MOST LIKELY
THIS WAS AN ACCIDENTAL LEAK FROM
A LAB.
>> SO TURNS OUT THAT METZEL WAS
NOT SPECULATING.
THEY FOUND THE OFFICIAL
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS WAS
DOCTORED AT THE SOURCE.
IN ONE INSTANCE, THEY DISCOVERED
THAT THE BAT LADY IN WUHAN HAD
COLLECTED SAMPLES OF A BAD
CORONAVIRUS THAT WERE VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO COVID-19.
WHERE DID SHE GET THESE SAMPLES?
SHE FOUND THEM IN A CAVE IN THE
HUNAN PROVINCE IN CHINA.
SEVERAL MINERS WERE KILLED THERE
AFTER INHALING THE BAT FECES.
SHE RECOGNIZED IT WAS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT MOVED TO
HUMANS WITHOUT GOING THROUGH AN
ANIMAL HOST FIRST.
THE CHINESE SEEMED TO BE LOOKING
FOR THE MOST DANGEROUS VIRUS
THAT THEY COULD FIND.
IN THAT CAVE THEY FOUND OUT.
AFTER THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
BEGAN, LI TRIED TO HIDE THAT
COVID-19 WAS IDENTICAL TO THIS
VIRUS THAT SHE SELECTED IN THE
MINE.
IN THE RECORDS, SHE RENAMED THE
VIRUS THE HIDED SOURCE.
AND PETER DASZEK PUBLISHED A
PAPER.
SOMEHOW AND YOU'LL BE SURPRISED
BY THIS, THEY OMITTED THE DEADLY
VIRUSES FOUND IN THE HUNAN MINE.
FUNNY.
WERE THOSE VIRUSES SIGNIFICANT?
THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA THINKS
THEY ARE.
LAST YEAR JOURNALISTS OF THE BBC
TRIED TO VISIT THE MINE TO GET
ANSWERS.
WHEN THEY GOT THERE, THEY WERE
FOLLOWED BY PLAIN CLOTHES POLICE
OFFICERS.
THEY FOUND THAT THE ROAD TO THE
MINE HAD BEEN BLOCKED BY A
BROKEN DOWN TRUCK.
SO THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
COVERED THIS UP.
HERE'S THE WORST PART AND THE
MOST SHOCKING PART IF YOU'RE AN
AMERICAN.
SOME IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HELPED THEM COVER IT UP.
THEY KNEW THIS WAS GOING ON BUT
BURIED THE TRUTH, TOO BECAUSE
THEIR INTERESTS WERE ALIGNED
WITH THE INTERESTS OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
CHRISTOPHER PARK SAID "NOT TO
SAY ANYTHING THAT WOULD POINT TO
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT'S OWN ROLE
IN GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH."
WHY WOULD HE SAY THAT?
TURNS OUT HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE
2017 DECISION TO LIFT THE
FEDERAL MORATORIUM ON FUNDING
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
VANITY FAIR OBTAINED A MEMO FROM
THE ACTING ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S ARMS
CONTROL BUREAU.
IN THAT MEMO HE WROTE THAT STAFF
FROM TWO STATE DEPARTMENT
BUREAUS HAD WARNED LEADERS IN
HIS OFFICE NOT TO PURSUE THE
INVESTIGATION OF COVID-19
BECAUSE IT WOULD OPEN A CAN OF
WORMS.
THESE ARE AMERICANS WORKING TO
HIDE THE TRUTH OF THE ORIGIN OF
COVID-19 FROM A COUNTRY THAT HAS
BEEN DESTROYED BY COVID-19.
YOU CAN'T PREVENT OUTBREAKS
UNLESS YOU KNOW WHERE THEY CAME
FROM AND YET FEDERAL BUREAUCRATS
PREVENTED US FROM LEARNING WHERE
THIS CAME FROM.
ONE OF THE OFFICIALS THAT WANTED
TO SMUT DOWN THE PROBE IS CHRIS
FORD.
A FORMER ADMINISTRATION FIRM
WITH DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PROBE, DIRECT KNOWLEDGE, TELLS
THIS SHOW THAT CHRIS FORD WAS
BRIEFED ABOUT THE LAB LEAK
INVESTIGATION EARLIER THAN
DECEMBER 2020 WHEN FORD CLAIMS
HE FIRST HEARD ABOUT IT.
WE'RE TOLD THAT FORD WANTED IT
SHUT DOWN.
HE WAS OVERRULED BY THE
SECRETARY STATE, MIKE POMPEO.
FORD WAS NOT A PERMANENT
BUREAUCRAT.
HE WAS A POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
HE SPOKE FOR MANY IN THE
BUREAUCRACY.
MANY OF WHOM WERE TOLD WANTED TO
BURY THE PROBE OUT OF POLITICAL
ANIMUS.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY SERVED
AND DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE IT
POINTS.
THEY ACCUSED ANYONE THAT ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE THE VIRUS
CAME FROM OF BEING A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST.
AND IN OUR CONFIRMIST CULTURE
THAT IS ENOUGH TO SHUT PEOPLE
UP.
THEY DID NOT ACT LIKE FEDERAL
OFFICIALS THAT WERE SWORN TO
PROTECT AMERICAN LIVES.
THEY WERE NOT PROTECTING
AMERICAN LIVES.
THEY WERE PROTECTING THE
CONSENSUS AND THAT ENDANGERED
AMERICAN LIVES.
MSNBC ANCHORS HAVE REGRESSED TO
CHILD-LIKE INCOHERENCE.
WATCH THIS GIRL DROOP OVER FAUCI
LIKE HE'S THE BASSIST IN A GIRL
BAND.
>> YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE WITH THE DATA.
I WAS TRYING TO TELL THE TRUTH
ON THE BASIS OF WHAT THE DATA IS
AND IT WAS NEVER DELIBERATELY
SOMETHING AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
IN FACT, HE SPOKE ABOUT MY
E-MAILS.
LOOK AT MY E-MAILS.
I NEVER SAID ANYTHING DEROGATORY
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THE TRUE MARK OF SOMEONE IS
IF THEY LOOK GOOD WHEN THEIR
PERSONAL E-MAILS COME OUT.
YOU PASSED THE TEST.
>> Tucker: I LOVE YOU, TONY
FAUCI.
STILL TALKING ABOUT TRUMP.